is what you can get to commit to you if
the man that you can get to commit to
you you feel like are below your league
you're delusional yeah the men the men
just because you sleep up doesn't mean
they'll commit to you can't answer the
delusional though because it's
delusional it's not because everyone's
different everyone's different you don't
know everyone's situation so I was
actually engaged about to get married
and I called it off so I wasn't
delusional so I was with someone for six
years about to get married wedding
period of everything yeah that's your
level because you're not committed to
you yeah yeah
yeah I get that what you mean because
he's the one who obviously proposed the
men preposition yeah I've had people
want to do it and I'm like no because
you're not my guy you're not and if he
committed to you that's your life
cause I'm saying no because you're not
that guy I'm still waiting for an answer
why these men that you're supposedly on
the level that you're on are not
committed I didn't see it I was on a
level I'm saying you've got to date
within your lane no